okay let's play london
not berserking i'm gonna keep this chill
and
educational i'll treat this
as knight c6
so with knight c6 we can still i mean i
could play d5
i don't know if i've ever actually
looked into this
specifically but
um maybe after the game i'll have to
check this it's like an alekhine's
defense against d4
but for the sake of simplicity i think
uh
a london is nice to stick with and yeah
with the knight committing itself to c6
it's more
likely i'll end up playing c4
wow f6 so against f6
i think wait a minute
i'm tempted to play e4 hoping for g5 and
then just mate
uh the thing is black wants to play e5
here
so i could play knight f3
yeah let's discourage so i'm
discouraging e5
i'm also preparing d5 and then if 95 i
would just win upon
and this move i'll just kind of calmly
move back
oh black really wants to play e5
you're absolutely brilliant to love you
man oh i love you too
microwave soup thanks for that
um and this is classical i have time to
think
uh let's play d5
i mean yeah like you don't see this
every day
it's hard to punish though but this is
my best attempt at punishment
yeah my opponent's provisionally rated
but no mercy and no mercy
even against maybe newer players
thank you emblem with 100 bits
and stogran solving for four months
okay so this night i could keep kicking
around
um in general probably just want to
focus on development
yeah let's just play
normal opening principles
so far it's a good example of like one
side following opening principles
another side like moving the same piece
twice
playing some questionable pawn moves
but i'm going to be patient now with e5
i can on poisson
i'm allowing the bishop to develop but
then i'll probably play e4
and try and enjoy the position
okay i'll play e4
i mean given the opening
i would have liked to punish blackmore
um but i can't complain a simple
development
it's not easy for black to complete
development on the kingside
basically the bishop and knight are both
fighting for the same square
and this is one reason to avoid playing
f6 early on
as you kind of hamper your own
development
oh and thanks brian yeah brian's active
it's on discord and in chat
okay so f5 is inviting
a nice little fork
uh so hitting the bishop and the pawns
also attacked twice
now there is a tricky move here queen e7
where then if i take the pawn black can
do
like crazy i'm just gonna say bishop b3
with check
so if we seven i just have to be careful
that my king doesn't get
punished i'm realizing if
if queen e7 maybe i still take because
bishop b3 doesn't do much my knight
defends c2
oh that's a move too i'll quincy it
defends the bishop it also defends the
pawn
okay let's take
so the main goal is getting initiative
completing development
um expecting takes
and then i'll play the goal is to play
vision b5 queen e2
have all the pieces in action
oh how do i get red arrows
you just have to believe hard enough
also hold down shift so right clicking
and dragging defaults to green holding
down shift
is red alt is blue and then shift alt is
yellow
as far as i know these are the only four
colors you can make
so for those of you who uh
who watched i guess the first part of
our lesson
we we covered a game where maiden one
was missed
this queen move the kiss of death
checkmates
do i remember when my alt key was stuck
yeah i do
i think it was a sticky shift i think it
was more of a software
problem rather than the hardware problem
but it led to me kind of ferociously
shaking the keyboard
yeah queen h5 was also possible but then
g6 or this
okay so the knight is pinned to the
square
i'm looking for fancy moves
oh let's just play simple chess it's a
position there like
there's a lot of ways to try and attack
but i just want to build
build up a little bit more pressure
and eventually the king's gonna be
suffering
there's this idea this idea maybe this
and this
lots of fun to be had
and lots of tea to be lots of tea to be
drunk
or drink
lots of tea to drink how about
[Music]
and a night to capture
oh leo says my coach also says a kiss of
death checkmate
i forget where i learned it there's some
coach who says it
i can't remember
it may have been like the the some
chassett3 company
where they teach chess to like toddlers
and they use fun analogies
i forget though
i sometimes also say the the inyo face
checkmates
it's a very common type of checkmate
when i teach kids it's like usually the
first mating pattern to address
what do i do for a living i
i i play moves and i thank people for
subbing with prime
things mr tomb something with prime
yeah my job consists of playing chess
drawing arrows and drinking tea
it's a nice job i enjoy it
i should update my bio yeah my website
is
maybe a little bit last time it was
updated was maybe a couple years ago
i take pictures too yeah
except not recently
was the last picture i took let's see
oh yeah no i i took a picture a couple
days ago i took a walk
and there were there were
ducks right
or there was a singular duck and maybe
some other bird type things
um
but that's more of a more of a hobby at
least these days
can people make a living only from chess
um well there there's opportunity to be
entrepreneurial in the chess base
uh which is i i guess what we're seeing
with streamers and coaches
um when it comes to playing chess
it's hard to make a living just on prize
money
it's been pretty pretty well accepted
like to make a good living
as a professional chess player
probably need to be within like top 50
to 100 in the world
but to make a living as like a coach or
streamer or content creator
or these days i guess there's commentary
you can
be you can work for a company like
chess24
chess.com chessable um
so that i think the industry is
definitely expanding
and there's job opportunities that are
related to chess in some way
that don't require being a strong chess
player
which is nice to see oh
so many appealing moves
play this move
here we go okay so this is this is a
photo i tried sharing
this is my walk the other day in the
park
what is this it looks like so it looks
like wow i didn't even realize i took
this
it looks like one duck that's like a yin
yang
half black and half white but it's two
is this a duck or like um one of those
puffin
furry birds and then there's surrounding
ducks
but i like how the white dot kind of
fits the shape
of the darker duck
uh my knights should be more powerful
than the
the rook i'm gonna keep the knights
now that the king is here it uh the pawn
is pinned to the king meaning this pawn
is
is undefended
and there's some nice x-ray vision
whenever you're in doubt where to put
your rooks
it's usually nice to put them aligned
with either
your opponent's king or queen or in this
case both
and hopefully good things will happen
what body of water was that uh
what do we call this a lake no a
probably a pond
not entirely swamp like
yeah kind of a pond but it might be like
like
it's connected via some kind of stream
or river
oh so opponent's defending
now i have a i have another fork
i wasn't interested in taking the rook
at the first opportunity
but now i kind of want to take the rook
because
when i take the rook then maybe i can
win the pawn
oh it's a pin yeah it's a pin party and
the opponent's not divi
invited or my opponents like the
the the person were surprising with the
party
how do i make this work because now
there's there's more alignment
man uh
i guess i'll just take i'll take the
rook we might trade queens but then i'll
win the pawn
i'll be up a rook what did the birds say
i think they chirped wait no ducks
wait what do ducks say alexa
what do ducks say
here's a duck quack
okay yeah that's a quack
i wonder how does that translate to
quack
it's just like some high pitched
like i don't even know
[Music]
okay am i mating
i'm close to mating the king is cut off
on both files
the thing is black can play king d7
and it's um
okay let's count here king d7 bishop c6
king nevermind
okay uh
interesting game
yeah so i think the biggest problem for
black was just
playing a few kind of sus moves in the
opening
got behind development i got more pieces
into play
the king lost casting rights so that's
why
usually it's better to stick with
something a bit more traditional
be a bit nicer to the pieces
okay life goes on that was the first
game
so i'm gonna play i'm gonna stick with
my promise
and play the openings that
uh that andre
would play and that's kind of the
openings that we went over so i'll play
sicilian
intending for a dragon not berserking
this tournament
i need to save as much time as possible
to
share pictures and tell stories about
birds
more you see the cool thing about google
photos you can type in like any
word and it'll just bring up photos
of said word
so like i type in bird
uh oops it brought up crisper
but yeah i type in bird and now now it's
just like bird photos
except this is a squirrel
i think
okay so we're gonna play a dragon
oh a dragon is a dragon a bird
dragons can fly right
alexa is a dragon a bird
no that's not true
oh okay
i'll believe you
what opening too strong
man yeah poland can deal with my pawn
chain
and my bishop diagonal
i guess uh
okay i should retire now
winning with the sicilian in two moves
i didn't even get to like show my dragon
that's okay oh
alexa is a dragon a reptile
no that's not true oh
you know best i guess wait are there any
like reptile birds
or flying reptiles
because most reptiles are like land
animals right
or sand animals
okay i'm gonna go back to london
oh like dinosaurs
hmm
or an arrow oh aerodactyl is that a
valid scrabble word
it sounds like it could be maybe
potentially valid
okay london time yet again
we'll see what the opponent wants to do
[Music]
oh i didn't recognize this flag in
trinidad
and tobago okay so d6
signifies boxing to play king's indian
so i usually like to play knight c3 here
i'm going for
more of a pierce opening
oh thank you isabel hs
and skype 106.
man should really keep a counter of how
many prime subs have been today
i don't think i've ever received so many
prime subs in a single day
thanks people um
so i've had this position once
in a tournament game i went for this
interesting idea queen d2 bishop g7
bishop h6
okay but we're not going to see that
here
now is a decent time for e4
and thank you we qtacs slaving with
prime
oh if you launch them with enough
velocity
all reptiles can fly good to know
so queen a5 it's an attempt to basically
play e5 next
which i think i'm okay with
or am i
a3 is kind of interesting
i was thinking queensland castling but
then
[Music]
uh black would have b5
and the problem is that b4 would
threaten not only to win this pawn
but also this pawn like my knight would
be kind of
doing too many things
so i like a3 because now black has to
constantly worry about b4
whoa it's four dollars hey eric i am
raising 14.50 on liches and consistently
run into a lot of players who don't play
traditional openings would you recommend
i spend more time studying tactics
to punish their dubious moves or
prioritize theory
i play mostly rapid classical
[Music]
uh oh you're rated around 1450
yeah so at that level you're not gonna
run into like so many mainline things as
you would against maybe a stronger
player
or just stronger players in general
and also like the majority of your games
probably won't be determined in the
opening
they're usually determined by
tactics or
[Music]
time management so
um you'll probably get more value from
like sharpening your tactics developing
your patent recognition
and um but then it doesn't hurt to
like try and take away lessons from the
openings that you are running into
and try and reflect like if you play
if you play a few dozen games see what
you're running into most often
and where the improvements could be
so it's still good to keep some balance
h6
kind of a slow move
very tempted just to expand here
like b4
maybe it's not necessary
this is another option
let's play this i'll still have the
possibility
of playing before i still might want to
castle queenside
if i castle queenside i don't want to
commit to this
so i hope i gave you some insight there
um but yeah like when it comes to chess
study
if if you are devoting some time to
studying in addition to playing
it's good to mix things up and and like
do tactics
analyze your games analyze the games of
good players
you can use the databases to like check
the openings that you're running into
even if they're
more obscure openings you can usually
find
the games of strong players and then see
what they do
but yeah it's good to hear okay you're
playing rapid in classical so
yeah you'll learn learn more from the
slower games
um b5
so i could start with b4 here
because the thing is if i play bishop b3
b4
i'm kind of losing a pawn
i could play bishop a2
so these are probably the two there's
also bishop d3
um let's play b4 first
i have a sense of what my my kind of
long-term strategy is
assuming black retreats somewhere i'll
play bishop b3
and then the game plan is to castle king
side
put a rook on e1 and try and bust open
the center
then in the meantime it's not clear what
black's king is doing
as if black wants to do this and this uh
the pawn will be hanging with the
battery
so black's gonna have to play some move
like this or this and then
it's a bit weakening and the king stays
in the center for too long
then um
like after e5 happens it's hopefully
going to be nice for me
so
i'm not sure if everything will work out
so perfectly but
i have a good idea of what my next few
moves are
oh question from wander shout out to
wander by the way
very strong scrabble player and scrabble
streamer
laundry 15. i was actually watching
wander
last night playing some strong scrabble
i was asking does stockfish always use
the same opening
um so when it comes to openings and
engines some engines will have a
built-in opening book
but then engines will determine moves
based on
like the cpu power and the depth
so it can vary and in general engines
don't have the best understanding of
openings like humans actually still
probably have
better understanding of what openings
are more effective
just because like after even after like
four or five moves there's
there's just so many possibilities a
computer can't crunch through
um
like there's some there's some effect
called the horizon effects
where after like a few moves the engine
just will
uh there'll be so many possibilities
that it won't be so useful
but it's still it can still be helpful
and like these days
engines are more
they're more of a tool to help humans
like better prepare
and sometimes they're finding they're
good at finding ideas that
a human wouldn't otherwise find that's a
good idea
knight c4 black wants to win the bishop
here
so i'm debating whether to allow this or
i could prevent it as queen e2
leaning towards preventing it
i could also allow it
and allow queen dig's bishop and get the
f
[Music]
file
now let's play queen e2
keeping control
and this probably gives black more
decisions to make too
okay a few people to thank few donations
to address
um oh but now i don't have my battery
so black's probably gonna castle unless
i do something crazy
i could play this move
it's actually kind of a cool move
let's do it
let's do it
i'm relying on some intuition here
but
it's interesting unleashing the queen
kind of pressuring this pawn maybe
enabling g4
[Music]
i might just go completely insane and
pawn storm
okay let's thank some people thank you
sergeant cole
solving for six months
half a year thanks so much and zozo so
many sevens
maybe seven sevens also subbing for six
months
and drafa says
love your content just had a baby you
work from home
watch your videos all day got back into
chess while i take care of the baby
oh that's nice to hear oh shout out to
your baby
and thanks for the 200 bits
and cole m cole another new sub with
prime
oh okay so this is the first like real
blunder by black
um i was talking about this concept with
andre
it's a overworked piece this pawn is
defending too many things at once
so i can take here first
and this is all collapsing for black
because after it takes i'll take here
attacking the rook and also attacking
the knight
yeah maybe i could have taken here first
i'm not sure though it probably works
because after it takes i
attack the knight and the bishop
but yeah this is
this is simple
so one thing i guess i didn't mention
but after the h4 i'm preventing black
from castling
because if black castles this pawn would
be pinned
and i would be able to take here so
yeah that h4 it was it was an aggressive
move but it was also prophylactic move
oh i didn't mean to shout at the baby
just
give a shout out to the baby
sorry if that wasn't clear yeah i don't
really enjoy
shouting at babies or just shouting in
general
oh current sub count is 16.99
almost a nice number
also there is a one dollar donation from
uh kozan saying
something something something this one
no not that one well i am here for three
months now i feel like oh
one third of a baby thanks carlo
yeah this message channel is growing
rapidly
maybe it's time for to make some
improvements
uh decent background improvement or a
new camera
or something like that make stream more
professional
you can use my one dollar for that oh i
appreciate that
i did so i upgraded uh microphones
recently
got this um this baby
it's a shore it's the new shore mv7
the microphone for noobs but also like
good quality
and
[Music]
yeah i've been i've been researching
other types of things
i might get some better lighting um
i mean the shelf behind me is also new
i needed somewhere some some place to
put my
uh my youtube button
and and the books all the books and tea
that people have sent me
um yeah at some point i might
wait what oh wow so my
the games i'm black i'm just winning
really before the game starts
the previous black game i i had one in
two moves
and i gained one rating point for that
too let's go
so i actually i do have a camera like a
nice quality camera i use for
photography
um that i ran into
into some issues using as a webcam
so it's more of a a matter of
troubleshooting
than uh than getting equipment
it might require just a better capture
card
so c6 let's play knight d2
c6 is a bit um
i will say i play this as black and
usually if i play c6
the idea is to meet e3 with g5 and
bishop takes g5 queen a5
is a a nifty trap so i'm going to play
knight d2
because now g5 i can safely take it
g6 okay let's play this controlling the
center
also thank you smith reed
or schmidty solving with prime
let's be solid and bologna
bolognese something at tier one
thanks so much
did alpha 0 find the refutation to 1 e4
can you find something that doesn't
exist
i don't know oh it's a berlin
okay i guess that's solved then
okay so b5 sometimes when b5 is played
too early like even if though it's
supported
i can challenge it with a4 let's do that
it's a classic kind of positional moment
and black would like to play a6 but that
would i think lose a pawn because it
takes
there'd be some eventual pin
and in this case then this pawn is a bit
lonely
now the plan is to just build a pressure
on the a file
okay black gets some initiative
play rook a3
rook a2 is met with this
oh wonder getting two elgato key lights
today nice
yeah i know elgato elgato makes a lot
of things for streamers
i have uh actually have the elgato green
screen
i think
this thing
is that better no
i'll have a more uh
visual background
yeah i feel like a key light would
probably go good with the
green screen yeah my main lighting
source is one of those like dumb
walmart lamps actually i think it's a
target lamp
it's f5 so black wants to trap my bishop
i have to be careful here
it's interesting like blocks playing
aggressively
but also kind of anti-positionally
even though there's a tactical threat
there's going to be
long-term weaknesses
hopefully so let's start by taking
mainly looking at this pawn
oh oh there's a cool idea i can take the
bishop
this looks like the most natural but
then bam
oh but does it not work it almost works
ah it's a calculation
i just assumed this wins material the
the thing is there's knight f4
that i can take and then takes and then
check
rook f7 knight g5 if king h8 still my g5
threatening this of queen f8
where's my win my pawn is kind of
ridiculous on g4
one more time g4 knight f4 i really want
to play this move but
i don't want to lose my queen
so g4 knight f4 takes takes queen e6
king h8
i mean i don't have to go into that
i could be civil i just play this move
question the pawn
let's play this move
yeah rather than going for some
questionable like
tactical variation which probably
doesn't work for me
this is just more kind of pure
positional play
i pin the pawn unleash the queen
there's still lingering ideas of maybe
playing this eventually
i just want to get the pieces to good
squares
oh this among us clip
you know this um i guess some people are
still using the among us command
i never recovered after falling through
the hole
i don't post it on youtube actually
oh no
okay everything's normal
where's my tasks so i can i can do
[Music]
wait what wait what
[Music]
it's like what happened did i
accidentally vent
no oh no no
[Laughter]
should we let him kill some people first
rebecca why'd you hit the button
okay did eddie quake upload to something
no i fell through like a hole and then
[Music]
becca you're not supposed to hit the
button
[Music]
i i began making a thumbnail
this is my thumbnail so far
it was kind of hard to like visualize or
like design a hole
i wasn't sure whether to add my face
i don't know it's a work in progress
actually um well i wanted to do with
that clip i was going to post like the
one minute clip
on youtube but then it came out to be
like a minute
and five seconds
wait what does this move
i really still want to play this
but again knight f4
or even wait the bishop's attacked but
now it's complicated
i could start with this
[Music]
this is kind of a cool move too
maybe i'll play this
because the knight wasn't doing anything
anyway on d2
to put my pieces to work
oh people saying add the face
yeah there's different there's different
ways to add the face
i could make my face i don't know
i could make my face smaller
i can just have like my mouth i don't
know
i'll play around with it
oh yeah i was trying to explain so with
youtube
youtube released a new feature recently
that maybe not everyone is
aware of
what is this f file what's going on here
so okay there's there's maybe three
options i could take
i could take or i can move the queen
somewhere
if i take here the problem is my bishop
and queen would then be hanging
but there's a line
[Music]
actually there's a line so if takes
takes
then i take and then the rook's just
awkward
and i have queen e6 actually looks nice
for me
and if takes rook takes is playable
and then queen e3 and the knight and
rook are attacked
or maybe queen d2 queen e3 there's
knight d5
wait one more time so takes rook takes
queen d2
i think i'm just winning a piece there
or some material
and it takes pawn takes let's be precise
takes takes queen e6 king g7
i'm maybe not trapping the rook
like the rook's hard to attack but i
just play rookie one
and position it looks really really good
so yeah let's start with this
i just realized wait
i just realized after this no after this
this there's knight c4
oops
okay but we're not going into that
okay so here i i have to take
[Music]
that's funny like if there's anyone just
tuning in who didn't see the previous
moves
it's hard to imagine how a rook can just
be on f4
just chilling because that file is now
closed
but if the rook comes back here it's not
getting trapped
so it's a question i should probably
start with this
i mean the other move to consider is
rook a1
but then there's some queen d7
so maybe check and then rook a1 and then
the queen is more limited
yeah at this point i'm trying to keep
initiative
and keep improving the pieces
okay i should predict what block's going
gonna do
g the only move to defend the pawn is
queen c7
and then everything is tied down kind of
lights restricted but i'm not sure if
there's a knockout below
[Music]
it feels close
it feels very close
what i could do is rook a1 queen c7 and
then rook
goes to e1 threatening this
okay let's start with this
what was i talking about and the
position became more interesting than
whatever i was talking about
something among us oh yeah so i was
going to try and um
use this new youtube feature so youtube
released
what's called youtube shorts which is
basically their com like their
competitor product uh
rivalry rivaling uh tick tock
where if you post like a video less than
one minute
it'll be promoted in like their shorts
feature
um so i'm probably gonna post the among
us clip as a shorts video
which takes a little bit more editing
work
okay so let's go for this
it's okay so i'm threatening this if
knight d5
i have c4
really i'm just threatening to win a
pawn because after here takes takes
k moves takes and life should be good
oh also thank you oh 10 minutes ago i
don't think i read this name
gear gear crawley solving for three
months with prime
appreciate that oh that's a good move
i played this or this
oh i have a cool idea oh i missed it
here though i could have played queen
i could have played queen a2 winning the
pawn oh but then knight c8
i should have considered queen a2
how'd you do this because the rook's
going to come here and block's going to
be very solid
i have an idea involves
doesn't quite work though i was thinking
here
oh wait a minute if i play here
wait a minute oh we had this so we could
repeat actually if i play here
black could repeat with this
which i'd probably be okay with i was
looking at rook a1 rook
f7 and then takes
which is also interesting
another idea is to play rook a5
to discourage this rick from coming here
oh that might be more effective
so i could force a queen trade so here
here
takes takes rook a1
and there's still knight c8
i'm looking for punishment it seems like
black's
just like barely defending in all these
lines
another possibility is c4 and just go
for the throat
wait what about queen a2 initially queen
a2
that's still knight c8
the thing about this position my
knight's not doing anything
i want my knight to do something
so i could play like this this this
or maybe dance somewhere
what does black want to do
we got five and then what
realizing black's restricted so there
might be time for me to
[Music]
like slow play a little bit more
like maybe just go after this pawn
and the benefit with moving the knight
is i can play g3 with tempo
[Music]
let's move the knight the rooks and
queen are happy
it's really the knight that needs
improvement
always got to be mindful about getting
skewered
but i control the e-file for the time
being
i guess the one possibility for black is
to play this this this
but i should have enough time to defend
okay so maybe now
well if i played knight e4 there's
rookie seven
and that would be bad that would be
really really bad
or would it
oh there's a cool idea
that's a really cool idea uh
if i play 94 allowing rookie 7
and then hope it's not really really bad
because there's a really cool idea
wait knight e4 rookie seven
[Music]
there there there there there wait i'm
just winning there
i think it's okay
i'd better be okay
i don't want to say anything too
revealing
opponent could always be watching so i'm
allowing
i'm allowing black to skewer my queen
and knight
on the surface it looks really bad
because like if i take
those takes takes and mate
i'm down a lot of time yes the phone's
been moving quickly
um i mean if black doesn't play this i'm
ready to win a pawn maybe fork on the
eighth rank could be nice okay
so black black plays this move so my my
secret
hopefully brilliant ideas play knight c5
or knight g5
not sure if there's a difference
i mean the whole point is i allow my
queen to be taken but then i win it back
and
then i'll be up a rook
i think knight c5 is probably the way to
go
oh wait a minute oh am i not winning oh
no
wait no it's still okay i think
i realize there's a move i didn't
consider knight c5 knight d5
uh defending the rook and keeping the
skewer
but then i can take in 96
so i think it's okay what
robocalls okay
so let's play knight c5
i think i like this move better because
i have access to d3
it's a funny position a lot of things
are hanging
but i'm attacking i'm attacking the rook
even though my queen and knight are
hanging if black takes tonight i win the
rook
if black takes here i'll win back the
queen and be up a rook
and if knight d5 or knight c8 i can take
and if knight takes i fork if queen
takes we trade i have rook a7 in the end
and i should end up being up a pawn
actually no i'm gonna fork in the end
yeah so i take here
if queen takes i take take and then fork
and if here i'm again winning the queen
i'm winning a rook here
that was nice it's kind of a cool uh
a tactical sequence
okay man
took some calculation
i think this was kind of an instructive
moment like this sort of position
because there were a lot of different
ideas but really
it just came down to asking myself the
right question
of which piece out of these pieces
is not doing anything
which even though the knight was it was
on a decent square it wasn't doing
anything
and then it it managed to do better
and more powerful things
yeah i think it's winning but maybe
black should play this move this is
probably the best try
i don't think rook e7 yeah
so yeah knight c5 and knight g5 are
similar
rook f7 yeah so rook f7 the game would
continue
but positions pleasant for for white
and the night uh i found a better home
okay so for the last like several moves
that game i was not looking at chat
[Music]
it's usually the case if the position
gets complicated i don't want to
look at chat and look at move
suggestions
um yeah i came from um
i guess solid opening but yeah
positionally i was uh
so i was always happy with the the
situation
okay let's move on it is tiring to play
like at least higher quality slower
games
but uh keep chugging away
okay um why playing d4
so i had the lesson earlier with andre
he plays king's indian except this is
this is a trompowski
um against tromposky i like to play d5
so this is not going to be king's indian
this is going to be
[Music]
what i like to play g6 is still a
playable move
you know e3
c5 is uh is fine here think the main
line
instead of e3 i think this is a bit more
common
hi eric nice to see you
oh good to see you too who was that
that was e weiger zuge subbing for three
months
and just win bb gifting a sub
to zippy dos thanks for that
yeah so there's a bunch of things black
can play against uh
trompowski um
this line is inspired by
carlson karjakin 2016 the first game of
the
world championship match featured
something like this
which it may have been this exact
position
i don't recall c3 being a main move
but it's playable
man i'm calculating a line where i get
mated there's a funny line uh
queen b6 queen b3 c4 queen c2
bishop f5 typical idea to deflect the
queen from defending the pawn
but after queen takes f5 queen takes b2
there's queen c8 mate
so let's not get mated
i could take
i'm not sure whether i should be
concerned about lights maybe taking and
eventually defending
because there's a line knight c6 takes
e5 b4
i mean i could play queen v6 and then
maybe just leave the tension knight c6
that looks reasonable
and here i'm not scared of taking
because takes all
attacked the rook and then the pawns
would be weak
yeah i actually went to new york
what was it november 2016
it was around november 10th
ish um
that was actually the first ever world
championship match i attended in person
and i showed up without any tickets but
i showed up with a camera
and they gave me a press pass
oh do i take opening suggestions
sometimes
but this at least these games i'm
playing
i'm playing the openings i was teaching
earlier
so earlier i had a lesson with
uh andre guilhoto
and uh he had a pretty specific
repertoire
of uh king's indian for black
london for whites we looked at some
dragon lines
so um
but okay this opening this opening is a
bit different
and we're gonna have a positional game i
like the structure
even though i have two sets of double
pawns
my my pawns have moved closer to the
center
one step closer of getting a a central
pawn cube
let's play rook rook g8
thank you kron double seven and solving
for three months
have i ever gotten a speeding ticket
i have gotten pulled over i can share my
my stories
but never no i've never gotten speeding
tickets
my bishop f5 the first time i ever
got pulled over like late at night
and i had no idea what i did wrong
and then the cop came to the the window
and basically said the best thing i
could possibly hear
was that he had misread my license plate
like he just misentered a digit and said
that i was free to go
and said sorry it was nice
and then i actually i did get pulled
over for violating a rule that i didn't
know was a rule
i guess i'll share it just so other
people are aware and don't make the same
mistake
because it wasn't so intuitive
um i was dry so i i was driving in
iceland
i went to iceland for uh my first time
actually
traveling to europe i was there for two
days
rented the car
and in the u.s so actually before
even before i ran to the car i looked up
like all the driving laws and
there's a whole video explaining what
like what you should be careful about
so i thought i was pretty well prepared
but there is a rule in iceland that
isn't the same case with the us
in the u.s you can make a right turn on
red
if there's no cars coming and
there's no signs telling you not to but
in iceland
you can't make a right turn on red
like ever so thankfully the cop was nice
gave me a warning
i learned my lesson
so yeah it's it's good to uh like be
aware of the driving rules when you
guess when you drive in different
countries
enjoying the stream oh thanks
i'm enjoying your bits microwaved soup
appreciate that okay
let's focus on chess it's kind of a
interesting position
i mean look at my pond i have a pond
house
just a nice little house
of ponds shouldn't probably put
back the bishop so the minor pieces are
occupying the house
three bedrooms a few guest rooms too
kitchen office space
closet
front yard
let's play this move
i want to open the file and if white
takes uh
i mean maybe white could actually hold
on to the pawn but
probably not oh there's actually a nice
line if white takes i attack the pawn
if white defends the pawn i take this
pawn attacking the knight
and then everything crumbles for white
oh no turn on red is everywhere in the
eu
okay
yeah i think i've i probably would have
assumed that but that's good to know
um is the house
solar powered i don't know
i don't need solar panels yet
and white's actually really solid too
white has like a tp
or gazebo
i might as well i'm just born cloud
delayed bomb cloud unpinning my knight
now the knight is actually kind of more
useful
oh can you turn left on red wait
maybe i'm not following the context
there's some countries where like they
draw
they drive on the other side of the road
uh like australia
or
of various other places so that requires
like i guess there's different
there's different rules depending on the
place
all right white's being very very solid
okay it's going to take work to to crack
the position
i was thinking of knight a7
[Music]
i mean f5 is another idea
maybe f5
calculating takes takes e4
which is kind of annoying
because takes takes bishop's hit d5
comes
i could throw in this move and so much
tension
also play this move
[Music]
oh i have a cool move c4 leaving the
bishop
unable to retreat
let's play c4
so i relieve the tension between the
pawns but um
i kind of like this now the bishop will
be more likely eventually to take
i might even be having ideas of just
maneuvering the night now leave the
bishop
without a purpose in life
there goes my pawn house a pond house is
just
undergoing some renovation the roof is
expanding
this is now my chimney
okay so this is a move but then doesn't
really accomplish much but i might need
to do it because
white wants to just win a pawn and
taking
yeah taking doesn't seem so appealing
either
let's push
i mean maybe long term this pawn this
pawn is fixing the pawn on h3 so
there's some positional benefits
yeah f5
that's still a tense position
[Music]
that's the problem with f5 is fill this
line with e4
maybe rook a5
yeah rook a5 is actually kind of
forceful
because if a4 then knight a7 i win a
pawn
i think
or not oh look at this line a4
rook a5 knight a7 b4
it's kind of dirty and then if i take my
rook is trapped
i guess i could take c3
not so weak
[Music]
okay so i'm trying to figure out how to
justify this line
like takes takes takes that's just worse
for me
[Music]
well i could do it's weird but rook a5
assuming a4 rook just goes back and then
the bishop can't retreat and then i play
knight a7
and the long-term idea is to take uh
pawn takes and then bishop d7
and win the pawn let's do that
i think it's more likely white will take
but we'll see what happens
yeah okay the house is continuing to
transform
what are these ponds wow white's house
who has a better house
i mean we both have all eight pawns i
just have more double ponds
more pawns closer to the center
as it's knights versus bishops
and positions about to open up
bishops can't be so bad
i just don't know trying to figure out
how to
approach uh
like determining what to do in this
position
i guess the first question is what does
white want to do
because either capture isn't so
threatening
so i might just leave all the tension
and like if i capture either thing that
allows the knight to come in
keep the tension wait a minute what
wait didn't you sub yesterday
i'm so confused justin blew subbed
yesterday but now has subbed again
because deja vu and subbing for 23
months thanks for that
i don't know how that's some kind of
magic trick or something
or maybe i just hallucinated
i'm not sure and deja blue
yeah i'm so confused
but this position is just as confusing
man
okay so what are my ideas if my pawns
aren't going to move
how do my pieces improve
i can play rook b5
but that's just easily defended
i could play b5 but then that prevents
me from ever playing rook b5
and it's hard to actually get the break
in
so one benefit of playing b5 is to then
[Music]
eventually maneuver the bishop put a
rook here later play b4
[Music]
that's nice having time to kind of just
chill and think
i don't think i've fully answered the
question what white wants to do
though because white doesn't want to
take either thing
i guess white wants to just improve the
rooks
so i have time
hmm
okay rook b5 would prevent white from
improving the rook
so much
i mean maybe i can start with this
like just give white a chance to make a
mistake
and then later play this
i don't want to spend too much time here
eventually i'm going to have to try and
use the clock as a weapon
okay i'm probably going to stop looking
at chat for time being
you know i saw some moves being
suggested but i don't really understand
how they relate to this position
and and some not so good moves being
suggested
so yeah let's uh let's play the rest of
the game without looking at chat
and then later all i'll re-engage
so king e3
man that's such like a juicy looking
[Music]
meal
kind of like rook b5 first
i'll start with rook b5
yeah so i think the king on e3 is
more of a
it's more of a target than it is like
anything useful for lights
but the question is like how do i
actually destroy the king
there's this idea it's a little bit slow
but what is y doing in the meantime i
know c5
i promise e5 is takes and
maybe it's playable
[Music]
94 it just gets really messy
and d4 is always defended
c5 takes takes takes takes
lights come in
[Music]
i think i'd rather leave the tension
[Music]
maybe start with king d7
and just see what white does
and the benefit with king d7 is that i'm
maybe opening the possibility of rook e8
wow what does this move
now i'm very tempted to play c5 the
problem is white's threatening to trap
my bishop now
that's the one drawback of moving my
king here
um
i could just kind of stay calm and slide
over
i should consider taking twice
wait c5 here and then i could take and
get a cube
now let's leave the tension
i feel like the combination of this and
this white's asking to
um
to get punished it seems a little bit
self-destructive
but it's so double-edged thank you
peach peach bear or no peach beach
for sobbing appreciate that
okay
and there is this move
but no let's take first
okay so i could throw in a
it check really do that much
man my house is kind of no longer a
house what is it
it's like an alien spaceship
everything is randomly on the queen side
now
the focus should really be in the center
oh my pawn is weak
but white wait white's allowing this
man what's going on here's a crazy move
d4
takes and then this but it doesn't do
anything
i could play check here takes
that actually looks like it does
something
wait so check here
takes and then white has a choice which
to take
let's do it
so it's a question do i want to take and
potentially lose this pawn
i could also i could play f6 here
and just keep the structure lose upon
like f6 white could take and then take
here but then
d4 and it's kind of like an end game
gambit
okay i'm relying on intuition
yeah the center the center situation is
more important
than anything else
it's never too late to play f6
here i could take the pawn
i probably want to take the pawn because
i prevent the knight from coming
back to f3
and and the file's opening this pawn
could be like a monster
coming to e3 thanks for subbing
a fiozen
oh i think someone was asking earlier
what type of tea i'm drinking
i'm drinking morning dew green tea it's
really nice
um okay so i have e3 oh i have this move
if i play this move i'm just winning
i think i'm just winning the bishop has
has entered white's house
home intruder that's why you should
invest in a a security system
have to find a should get sponsored by
simply safe
home security wow
that ended kind of abruptly
it ended very roughly but that's the
thing like when there's so much tension
in the position
maybe like one wrong decision can lead
to
defeat yeah like could have tried to
fight
but yeah the knights
maybe the uh why white wants to maybe
like try and stack the exchange but i
take and then win this pawn
yeah everything kind of crumbles please
analyze
20 c5
c5 on move 20.
oh in this position c5 it's interesting
yeah i guess i was just trying to be
patient
um
[Music]
yeah so the the problem just from a
positional standpoint
when i move the c pawn i give up
on maintaining a pawn here so after it
takes takes
then this is a little bit less
appetizing maybe it's still fine though
like you get the nice bishop
um
and it's still a very tense position
like there's a lot of tension between
these pawns
i'm not sure i'd imagine the engine
would probably say close to equal
but let's see
yeah like a lot of moves i could i could
choose between
so c5 here also playable
it's just so hard to calculate i was
trying to be patient and let whites
kind of make do the the decision making
oh the whole chat was asking for wait
what
oh for c5 oh
yeah i mean at this point i want i
wanted to keep throwing pawns but i have
to
still focus on playing good moves
um
[Music]
and yeah it's a type of position like
the engine
it'll just spit out numbers and moves
but like a lot of the the moves are all
similar evaluation
so it really comes down to identifying a
more cohesive plan
that uh it was difficult to find
oh bishop c5 oh bishop c5
oh
[Music]
i didn't realize so i could play bishop
c5
and not have to retreat because after
this i take with check
it's funny if king takes i just chase
around the king
and if knight takes i got the bishop to
d5
probably should have found that but
okay that was a fun game
yeah the game ended for those of you
that didn't see the finish
the game ended
[Music]
with a a skewer from behind
okay oh yeah was this um
yeah carlson karjakin first game of the
the match in 2016.
um oh we actually followed
wait oh yeah carlson took here
that was an interesting line
oh my opponent's average rating is 16.50
do i play one more game i feel like the
games are increasingly taking more
energy
i'll play one more game
oh so some title players
yeah to to make a running for first like
it's kind of necessary to berserk all
the games
but i'm just trying to keep it chill
have some instructional moments
oh welcome back alex pierce
okay playing debu i'm sticking with the
same rapper tour
actually it's been a while since i've
just played like the same repertoire
like
in every single game in the tournament
i don't think this is going to be a 10
hour stream unless it is
oh so i was talking about this earlier
whenever black plays this move or this
move too early
then rather than playing the triangle
setup
we're going to play something that more
resembles a queen's gambit
and the point is to exert pressure
against d5
but also against b7 which is no longer
defended
let's play that f3 first and c4 is
probably coming next
thank you shampoosie solving with prime
oh yeah i don't think i acknowledged it
but did cross
whoa it's fifty dollars hey eric thanks
so much for the superb content i am
learning a lot
oh that's great to you here's something
towards your t fund in return
[Music]
i am running low on tea so
i'll definitely put that to good use i'm
gonna probably order more
nice loose leaf tea in the near future
thanks so much
jay perkin
i really appreciate that that means a
lot
i i was just about to say i didn't
acknowledge the fact that
i guess a 1700 subs were crossed
so yeah i do really appreciate like all
my all the
amazing support today
really nice to see
also appreciate this position this is
one of like the
the nice solid london lines
kind of leads to a very pleasant middle
game for white
oh i need a t command i need to compile
a list of like the
the various teas i i recommend
also the various teas that i've been
sent like
a lot of people send me tea as a as
fan mail
yeah i do have a mix of like loose leaf
tea but also just kind of standard tea
bags
or tea sachets
have i tried hojicha
uh i have not at least not knowingly
i feel like green tea from japan is
probably like the best
type of green tea that's where green tea
is born right
queen 85 so rather than going for
defense
of the pawn black's going for attack
calculating a weird line knight e4 takes
takes
queen c87
actually don't know what's going on
there
but i don't think it's likely black will
play this
we'll see and thank you
kale kalevag 95
and the nine use this for more tea bags
oh i'm gonna have a tea party
but not like the real like the political
party more like the
the hot soothing beverage
man to go tea shopping
yeah people have like tea
recommendations let me know
oh xd tulip watch the automate chess
video
was one of the funniest chess videos
ever oh glad glad you liked it
it was a bit different than normal
am i in t anonymous
uh i'm in what's the opposite of
anonymous
alexa what's the opposite of anonymous
anonymous antonyms are named dubbed
turned
notorious in star i'm a t star
or unanimous i'm t unanimous
yeah or infamous or famous
or all of the above so a6
it's ironic it tries to prevent b5
but it just makes b5 stronger
because the apon's pinned
yeah this is nice
whoa it's flats oh typical brit here
drinking his english breakfast
tea at 8 pm at 8 pm
wait i have some caffeine right i guess
if you want to stay awake
so i have what do i have here
i have the i don't know this is a rival
to
english breakfast or just a sibling
but it's irish breakfast
which i think it's similar
but it's irish wait what does this move
i guess i can win a pawn let's win a
pawn
yeah so the issue with a6 is that now
after takes i'm
i'm just winning the a pawn
oh that was actually a wise decision
because now
[Music]
like i want to take and just chill
develop castle
but then there's rook a1
if i take here probably don't want to
mess with this move
so it was kind of a cool idea
which ah it doesn't work i was thinking
rook a4
to then take take rook a b3 the problem
is bishop
c2 so i'm gonna have to do something
that's not
super comfortable
but
it should be completely fine so i'm
thinking takes takes
and then just bishop e2 rook a1 bishop
d1
bishop c2 castle we could trade
i'll be up upon
hey it's llama attack
or maybe it's spanish and it's yama
attack
thanks for subbing for two months
oh this is a typical move and black is
trying to get the bishop here
i'd rather not not concede
i might have to concede but let's
let's be annoying
bring back the duck content
do you guys want more photos of ducks
i don't know if i have more i'm gonna
type in ducks and see what comes up
oh wow i have lots of duck photos
uh oh and some non-duck photos
ah that's a good move
um i wanted to like do fancy things but
after takes takes rook b7
knight a4 bishop c2
i would lose a pawn
i could play this move but then
[Music]
let's just play back
okay get ready for some duck photos
so again i just type in i typed in ducks
wait let's do the game first
i'll show the duck photos photos
here we go okay here's my duck photos
these are st louis ducks and then
there's some weird like bird creature
just kind of chilling in the back
forget what they call this there's got
to be at least one bird expert watching
right
okay so this was original plan a goose
oh a stork
right
or crane wait
i'm familiar with paper cranes
i could castle but i could also should
probably use the king as a
actually let's castle
that way the the rook is defended
oh definitely a huron
wait here on
it's a stork
those storks are a bit more compressed
okay we're gonna have an end game oh
it's obstacle our bishops
so it takes some work
hmm
let me start with this move oh there's a
cool trap
okay
oh tricky
so these are the photos that google
brought up when i typed in ducks
most of them are ducks
oh this is a video actually a duck like
just
came up to me i wanted food probably but
i didn't have any food
so that went away
was that a mallard alexa what's the
difference between a mallard and a duck
according to an alexa answers
contributor a mallard is a type of
dabbling duck
oh
alexa what does dabbling mean
as a noun darling is usually defined as
no
dabbling very dear to another one dearly
loved
as an adjective darling is usually
defined as
very dear dearly loved for more
alexa what does dabbling mean
dabbling is a form of the verb dabble
which is usually defined as
to play and splash in or as if in water
especially with the hands
for more ask me to give you more
definitions like a duck
no thanks okay so this was my cool trap
was to confuse my opponent with the the
bishop
and then it's really hard
to stop bishop b7 bishop takes c6
so i think i'm winning this pawn and
then this pawn too
like the knight wants to somehow defend
but it can't
and black also wants a counter-attack
but
it can't
oh thanks for the kind comments big
cuadro
from switzerland appreciate that
what else floats on water
most boats hopefully
and probably like an air mattress
and cheap pedes gifting a sub
to cutford thinks she feed us
are those my pictures yes these are my
my google oh here's uh did we determine
what this is
so this is a stork
oh it flies so it's a real bird
i forgot i captured this like beautiful
video
uh oh that's actually an interesting
move
i think i'll go ahead and win the pawn
and we're going to have an obstacle
bishop ending but i'll be up
three pawns so it better be enough
what's an egret
oh maybe it's an egret
so this is an egret
yeah a kind of long neck
people were saying crane earlier
i don't think it's a crane
oh okay so
upon sacking got rid of my
at least some of my pawns but not all my
pawns
okay so the the way to win this is to
use a king
use a knight use a bishop help the pawn
promote
maybe win all of lax pawns
we'll see
oh more videos oh yeah i was i've seen
this bird
i don't know if i caught it on camera
but it was fishing
like it just sticks its neck in the
water and catches fish
but it's very like slow and then then it
just pounces
oh should i do bishop and nightmate
um only if it's necessary
what else do we have a lot of videos
of this egret
oh it's a puffin yeah
i posted this instagram this is a puffin
with like nice hair
look at that hair
and it's like very splash worthy
ges rose and face oh
geese thanks frenzy lee
with a geese free sub
okay so this pond is going to be
blockaded so i might as well win these
pawns
is it a muppet bird
maybe what's a muppet bird
oh the handsome puffin bits thanks for
that
the miller high life
oh like big bird i don't know
i typed in muppet bird
do they look similar
i don't know
oh best books are other ways to learn
about what to do in middle game after
developing
i mean one thing i can recommend is like
game collection books
like any books with annotated games
um
[Music]
hey it's a dollar something about
oh why don't i try to get to gm
uh nightbot can answer that yeah just
use the gm command
um yeah the other book i can recommend
when it comes to just middle game
positional understanding
is reassess your chest by jeremy sillman
it is kind of a higher level book but
it does a great job of breaking down
like higher level concepts
what was this game oh yeah
this game so there's a
i give black doesn't play a6 i still go
for this
there's an idea here to play bishop a6
and get in this move
um and that's a nice thing like even
going back
to like this position with this
structure it's just
like the ideas flow very very nicely for
white
what book do i recommend to learn the
london system
i have a london course it's a video
course
wait what did i do wait what
oh i did something oh i did there
that was weird i did something to chat
where it
um it asked me if i wanted to purge
delete everything
so london yeah
so a couple years ago maybe three years
ago
it was already a while ago but i made a
london course
it was like a london tactics course has
eight hours of video content
link is in the chat
i think the price the price in that link
should be the lowest price
at like 30 dollars because elsewhere
it's probably like 60 dollars
could my chest improve to gm level on
its own
so the thing with achieving like the
grand master title
it's not enough to just play online like
i would have to play in like really
serious tournaments
have to really work on
[Music]
my opening preparation like my high
level opening preparation
which is different from my dubious staff
or gambit preparation
i have to become a lot sharper
tactically work on time management
[Music]
and then i mean to get like gm norms and
to get reading
you have to travel a lot to like various
tournaments
uh so it hasn't been my priority in like
recent times
and like this past year uh
i haven't really had over-the-board
chess
but that's not to say i won't play more
at least when over-the-board tournaments
become more of a thing again
um
[Music]
and i went through a phase 20
maybe starting in 2016 but then after i
graduated
in 2017 i i lived pretty nomadically and
i traveled
like all over the world for for
competitions
um but it wasn't wasn't really a matter
of chasing a title it was more
using chess as a vehicle to travel
and i'm thankful to be at a level where
at least for international events i can
usually get
uh like accommodation covered
is there a big difference to playing
over the board then to online uh yes
like most over the board competitions
involve games
lasting an average of three to four
hours if not more
i played the tournament in indonesia in
20
it was 2018
and i had like a six-hour game
and there were two rounds a day so i had
to play a six hour game and then had
like another
like three or four hour game afterwards
the real commando subbing with prime
thanks for that
i should write a book on how to get a
pawn cube from each opening
uh i'd rather make a video series
but yeah there's so many book
possibilities
yeah if i got the gm title then
i am rosen would just stand for i am
rather than
international master
is this one any good stafford and
bowdoin kaiseritsky gambit
wait this one i was showing this earlier
this book is dedicated to me kind of
and to other people too hey
thanks ivi gaming hd
with a sub as far as i know this is the
only book written on the staff room
um
yeah i've i probably read through it in
the span of like 20 minutes because a
lot of the
lines of chairs uh
i've seen before but it has some some
nice kind of collection of games
i don't know if i'll ever write a book
but
i would like to to get around maybe to
self-publishing a course
oh is it possible to lose the i am title
so i think if you sorry what something
went wrong
quiet please try asking alexa quiet
quiet